le gouvernement trudeau veut changer
certaines règles de l'impôt et les
conservateurs tire à boulet rouge sur
les libéraux le gouvernement attaque les
gens qui créent la prospérité et zotac
idéologique dans le b boy deux arguments
qui ont attiré notre attention
on les invite le gouvernement veut que
ce soit plus difficile pour un
architecte un comptable un médecin de
prendre son salaire et de le répartir
entre les membres de sa famille pour
payer moins d'impôts argument des
conservateurs
si les libéraux vont de l'avant il y
aura des impacts dans le système de
santé
difficile à voir un médecin c'est ça la
politique
que proposent les taux au canada deux
tiers des médecins sont incorporés ils
ce sont eux qui pourraient être touchés
les conservateurs présume qu avec les
nouvelles règles
certains pourraient prendre leur
retraite d'autres réduire leurs heures
de travail et d'autres déménager c'est
une hypothèse ya un sondage qui a été
fait chez 500 médecins au nouveau
brunswick et 65 % d'entre eux disent que
oui ils pourraient réduire leurs heures
de travail
à la suite de ces mesures ça reste un
sondage un scanner pour les mieux nantis
et vieux making de leur côté les
libéraux insiste sur le fait qu'il vise
les riches mais en fait il y aura pas
juste des riches
ça peut toucher par exemple un
agriculteur qui décide de répartir son
salaire entre les membres de sa famille
en fait 80 % des familles qui utilisent
cette mesure gagne plus de 125 mille
dollars
et là on parle pour l'ensemble des
membres de la famille ça veut donc dire
que 20% de ces familles gagnent moins
125 milles si vous voulez qu'on vérifie
autre chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]